la deshumanización de la guerra captada
en cámaras un video que circula por
redes sociales muestra un presunto
soldado ruso decapitando a sangre fría
quien sería prisionero de guerra
ucraniano las imágenes se han viralizado
a través de canales de Telegram Pro
rusos el presidente ucraniano voló dimir
zelemski condenó el metraje y reiteró su
pedido de ayuda urgente a la comunidad
internacional
Hay algo en el mundo que nadie puede
ignorar Con qué facilidad matan estas
bestias Este vídeo la ejecución de un
cautivo ucraniano el mundo debe verlo
Este es un vídeo de Rusia tal como es el
tipo de criaturas que son no hay
personas para ellos un hijo un hermano
un esposo el hijo de alguien Este es un
vídeo de Rusia tratando de hacer de esto
una nueva Norma qué hábito de destruir
la vida
el kremlin ha calificado como horribles
a las imágenes Aunque expresan que su
autenticidad debe ser verificada otros
organismos como Naciones Unidas y la
Unión Europea han vocalizado su
desaprobación para estos actos
Rusia debe cumplir su obligación en
virtud del derecho internacional
humanitario y garantizar que los
prisioneros de guerra reciban un trato
humanitario y en toda clase de
circunstancias de conformidad con los
convenios de Ginebra y que sus vidas no
corran peligro
la guerra en Ucrania es uno de los
primeros conflictos armados en donde las
redes sociales son protagonistas para
comunicar el acontecer de la guerra la
facilidad de acceso y la baja regulación
de sus contenidos pueden facilitar la
transmisión de imágenes brutales y
difíciles de comprobar su autenticidad